Speaker 1: Let's start today with what is
more horrible right wing news out of Italy,
where Italy is shifting dramatically to
the right, as the Associated Press reports,
rewarding Meloni's Party. Now, you may think
Maloney way you talk about Christopher Meloni,
the guy from Law and Order. No, no, no, no, no.
It has nothing to do with that. Let me tell you
what's going on in Italy. The AP reports a party
with neo fascist roots. The brothers of Italy won
the most votes in Italy's national elections,
looking set to deliver the country's first far
right led government since World War Two and
make its leader, Giorgio Maloney, Italy's first
woman premier. Near final results showed Monday
Italy's lurch to the far right shifts. Europe's
geopolitical reality placing a Euroskeptic party
in position to lead a founding member of the EU
and its third largest economy. Right wing leaders
across Europe immediately hailed Maloney's victory
and her party's meteoric rise as sending an
historic message to Brussels. Also a report
from BBC with a similar assessment and similar
analysis. Maloney is widely expected to form
Italy's most right wing government since World
War two. Now, if you're interested in the specific
policies that Maloney ran on and that her party
ran on Brothers of Italy, certainly take a look
at that. It is a more or less standard package of
this year. Some call it right wing nationalism.
Others say it really is neo fascist. Now, why
has this been happening in Europe? Because we've
seen it in Hungary. We've seen the rise of these
movements in the Czech Republic and Poland and
in many different places. Even some of the more
traditionally left wing countries like Sweden
have seen elements of this right wing nationalism
rise. The story that is told by the defenders.
You've got your strong defenders and your soft
defenders of this right wing movement. The story
they like to tell is a very similar story to what
those in the U.S. like to tell about Donald Trump,
which is these individuals have correctly
identified economic concerns and they've
coalesced those who feel as though they have been
left behind as open border immigration has been
welcomed and on and on. And they said, look, here
I am actually getting a message that makes sense,
which is we need to be it's simply about being
for the people that are here. It's about being
you know, in the U.S., the story was we want
a guy who is for Americans, not for China,
not for the Mexicans coming in through the
border. We just he's for Americans. That's
what's great about Trump. And it's a very similar
story that they like to tell about the rise of
these movements. Hey, listen, we finally have
someone who's going to speak up for Italians,
not Turkish immigrants or Moroccan, you
know, whatever whatever the country is,
depending on where in Europe you are. There's
nothing wrong with being for the French or for
the Hungarians. It's for us. It's good. That's the
story that's told. However, we know that it's not
really about those economic realities and economic
concerns because we have counter-examples you look
to really good examples are the Czech Republic
and Poland. In the Czech Republic and Poland.
There has been an improving economic situation
by basically every measure over recent years,
and yet support for this right wing nationalist,
neo fascist movement has grown in the Czech
Republic and in Poland over those years. So
there's two possibilities. One possibility is,
even though the economy has been improving, a lot
of people don't realize that. And so they say,
no, we need these right wing nationalists. Now,
that happens in the United States, people just
ignorant of the reality. I mean, look at right
now in the United States, despite some indicators
not being so good like inflation, we are close
to full employment and most economic indicators
are actually quite solid. You could have the same
thing in Europe. The economy is improving. People
don't believe it is. So then they go, We need
a neo fascist. That's one possibility. Turkey
possibility is it's not really about the economic
stuff. And in the United States, under Trump,
some people felt that it was the populist economic
message that attracted them to Trump. But we
know it was more than that. We know it was, if
not creating racism and xenophobia, certainly
welcoming it and saying you can all be part of
this movement. And so they found a home with
Trump. All of these things were really what was
going on. And so propaganda is a huge part of it.
Fear is a big part of it. We know that making
people afraid leads them to reactionary political
beliefs. When people become fearful, they
reflexively say, Well, let's do something
about that fear. Much like if you were convinced
that there was a really high risk of, for example,
a home invasion in your neighborhood, you would,
in a reactionary way, be willing to do all sorts
of things that maybe when you're clear headed,
you wouldn't be willing to do, whether it's buying
all sorts of guns or booby trapping or whatever.
Right. I mean, you get the idea. Fear gets us to
act in ways we would not normally act. And so fear
about immigrants from northern Africa has been a
big factor in Europe, us versus them ideology. The
European Union doesn't have our best interests in
mind. And, you know, it's similar to Trump stuff,
right? Naito naito, which doesn't have our best
interests in mind. These coalitions are bad,
NAFTA's bad. All this stuff similar sort of sort
of idea. So where we end up? Is with.
Speaker 2: The first.
Speaker 1: Presumably assuming in the next few
hours everything goes as is as it is expected to
go. The most right wing government in Italy
dating all the way back to World War two.
Scary stuff. And we're going to continue
following this rightward, rightward trend